She is so lonely and suddenly-
That's not an excuse, Brian.
... she has no family and this family invites her
and she is all of a sudden
accepted into this family group.
Do you not understand that that's the plot
of Dear Evan Hansen and everybody
hates that movie. It's the same-
But that's the thing. That's
the thing, they did it bad-
It's the same thing.
... and these guys did it right.
Today we're going to talk about the
most memorable holiday movie couples
ever and we're going to start with a hot
one. We've got this list on looper.com
and one of the items on the list is Jack
and Lucy in While You Were Sleeping. Now-
You're fired up, Brian.
... I watched this movie last year for the second
time because the first time I saw
it in theaters with my mom. And-
Right.
It's a nice movie. It's a nice
holiday movie. It's nice and fun.
Absolutely.
And I rewatched it last year and I was like,
"This is a sweet movie and I love it. And I
can't wait to watch it again." I think
it's great. I think that the couple in it,
Jack and Lucy played by Bill Pullman and
Sandra Bullock, Sandy Bully if you're cool,
I think they make a great... What Nina?
You seem confused by what I just said.
Sandy Bully. Just go on. Just keep talking.
Yeah.
It's fine.
You get nasty.
I do think, is it one of the most memorable
couples in a holiday movie? I mean, maybe?
It's a really nice holiday movie and
they genuinely seem to fall in love.
It seems nice. Tom, what were you
going to say about this movie?
Brian, you know what I like about that couple
so much is that they almost to the letter,
they mirror the relationship that I have with my
wife and that we met while she was pretending-
Okay, thank you.
That my comatose brother was her fiance. And
then she lied and lied and lied for like a month.
And everyone was cool with it eventually.
And then at the end of it, I was like, you
know who I want to do kissing with? That liar.
So here's my thing.
The con artist who worked her way into my family.
This movie is such a mixed bag for me because
Bill Pullman and Sandy Bully or
whatever, we're calling her today.
Right.
If you're cool.
Let's make that happen.
#SandyBully.
They do make a good couple and Jack and Lucy do
have good chemistry. And I like them as a couple,
but the circumstances in which
they get together to call it,
not ideal would be a large understatement.
Well, so that's the complication.
She's an unhinged, pathological liar.
Shes' a sociopath?
Yeah
No, no, no, no. Let's back up.
Here's how this movie goes.
I did back up, I backed up from
the ending that you liked to the
beginning part that's really messed up.
To the best of my recollection,
having watched this movie a year ago
once I recall that she has a crush on this dude?
That she's never spoken to.
Saves him from getting run over by a train.
Look.
Then casually, jokingly to herself says
I was going to marry that man. Someone
takes it out of context and suddenly-
Nope.
Is swept up in the situation.
And she doesn't say.
That's not.
Nope. That was not.
She tries to say-
That's not what happened.
I'm pretty sure she does try to say,
but she, but here's the thing, right?
Let us begin at the beginning.
Wait, Hang on.
This is going great already.
Hang on. She is so lonely and suddenly-
That's not an excuse, Brian.
She has no family. And this
family invites her and she is
all of a sudden accepted into this family group.
Do you not understand that that's the plot of Dear
Evan Hansen and everybody hates
that movie? It's the same plot.
That's the thing they did it
bad and these guys did it right.
It's the same thing.
Brian, read between the lines.
Let's start at the beginning.
She's a woman who looks and behaves like a
Sandra Bullock character in the early nineties.
And she's alone. There's a reason for
that. We don't get told what it is...
But there is one.
But if it's 1994 and you look like Sandra Bullock-
It's because her family's dead
and she doesn't know how to love.
How did they die? Do you think Brian?
I'm sure they explain it in the movie.
Do you think maybe it had anything to do
with the fact that there's a woman who,
when somebody goes to a hospital,
starts lying all the time?
Also, I have sympathy for a woman who falls in
love with Peter Gallagher's beautiful sumptuous
eyebrows. I have, we all have who doesn't love
Peter Gallagher and his eyebrows eyebrows?
The eyebrows you can get lost in physically.
But you can't lie just because of some great
eyebrows. You just can't. It's not okay.
They're eyebrows, not lie-brows.
Just take a moment for everybody at
home to recover from how hilarious I am.
Oh God. Continue.
So anyway.
Brian likes liars. Nina, what was your choice?
Nina, what's your choice now that we've
established that my I pick is garbage?
I'm going to talk about more garbage. So
every single year I have a holiday tradition
with my friends and we have an annual watch
of Love Actually. And when I say we have an
annual watch, I mean that one year we did it
without adult beverages and it was horrible
because I had to watch this movie with a really
clear head and it was really unsettling to me.
And so, there's a lot of memorable
couples in Love Actually. There is the
Colin Firth character, Jamie who purchases
a mute woman that he cannot communicate with
and then proposes to her with knowing literally
nothing about her. They can't speak to one
another. And I get that the gist is like,
oh, love, transcends language. And I'm like-
That's love actually. That's love actually.
Oh, I just read the title.
Actually it's not.
It's love actually.
Can you imagine because if I remember right, they
each learn like three sentences of each other's
language right? At the end, so that they could-
Yes. But they decide to get
married anyway, because, sure.
Well, I'm just saying. Can you imagine if
she had like, if the first thing that she
had said had been like, yeah. And also we need
to separate the races. Like if that had been-
What if that had been what the
relationship turned out to be.
Exactly.
I just with a racist UN accident.
That's the sequel Divorce Actually.
So yeah, so you've got Colin Firth
and his mute servant that he buys.
You've got Alan Rickman, R I P treating
beautiful, perfect Emma Thompson like garbage.
So like the Hugh grant and his like assistant
storyline is pretty endearing except for
the fact that like, he ruins a relationship
with his, with an international ally because
Billy, Billy Bob thorn hits on her. And also
everyone spends the whole movie calling Natalie
fat in the most descriptive ways. And I'm
like, she is a normal sized beautiful woman.
She's like normal looking. She's beautiful.
And everybody's like, oh, her thighs
are like- someone who works for the
prime minister is like huge thighs. And I'm like,
you should be fired immediately. Why do you
still have your job? That is so inappropriate.
She's legit gorgeous with a normal body.
Not only that, but how is
anyone who works in this office,
allowed to just freely comment on
a stranger's body? It's insane.
I have an answer for you.
Nina. That's love actually.
Oh, I just got the title.
Ah, you have like Liam Neeson who's just lonely.
But then he gets a Claudia Schiffer at the end
for some reason. You've got the little dude
from Game of Thrones who is bad at drumming.
Peter Dinklage?
Cut that we can't use that.
I think we can and we must. Go on.
No. I'm so sorry, Mr. Dinklage I love you.
What else?
No, we've got Jojo Reed from Game of Thrones.
And if he had been a child of any other race,
he would've been immediately tackled
running through that airport.
Oh no!
Because white kids can get away
with anything. Look, I don't know.
And we do.
Oh, oh. And then you do have, you have Keira
Knightly who is being stalked by Rick Grimes.
And he expresses his undying love for her by being
really mean to her all the time. And then making
out with her behind his best friends back. Great.
This is great. This is really good behavior.
And spending $40 at an Office Depot.
He got a bunch of poster boards.
He probably spent 40 pounds, which
is much more expensive than $40.
That's true.
And heavier.
So yeah, this movie is full of sociopaths.
The only good character is the guy
who moves to America and immediately meets three
super models who are obsessed with him.
And even that is weird and problematic.
The only good character is Mr.
Bean in the department store.
You're right. You're right. Actually, Mr. Bean
in the whole movie, he shows up multiple times.
There you go. Is he in not the department
store and other scenes? I don't remember.
He shows up in the airport and he helps out little
drummer boy, as he's on his and doing his run. He
stalls, like, can't find his passport.
So the kid can sneak through security.
Rowan Atkinson, is there anything he can't do?
He shows up somewhere else too. He's
in the movie like a couple of times,
because he's supposed to be. There's this
idea that he's like a Christmas angel who's
like preventing people from ruining their
lives. No, I'm just kidding. The best-
You know what his name in the movie
is? His name is love actually.
I have one final thing to say. The most
memorable couple from this movie and this
is actually a positive, I will say something
nice is Bill Night and his manager. Because
if there's one reason for this movie to
exist, it's Bill Nighy just being profane
and disgusting and perfect and wearing the
loudest shirts anyone has ever worn ever. And his
dorky manager whom he loves actually. So
that's the reason for the movie to exist but-
Full circle.
Anyway, I look forward to this holiday
season with a nice beverage and this movie.
Several beverages.
A bottle of beverages.
So we've got some items on this list on looper.com
that I will mention because I haven't seen all
these movies. I haven't seen all of the Christmas
movies out there, but I do love a good Christmas
movie. We've got Elf here, Buddy and Jovi. So
that's a fun little relationship. We've got the-
Is it? I mean he appears to be like a-
A man child.
Yeah. Like a man trapped, a boy trapped in
a man's body with an adult woman. Yikes.
Well, but that's the thing, he's
an innocent, fun Christmas Elf.
Sure.
And she is a single-
Sort of Tarzan if the jungle had been Christmas.
Yeah, exactly. Tarzan, if the jungle had
been Christmas and also Jane hated jungles,
but then was convinced to love jungles.
Because she worked in the jungle store.
Actually.
Actually. It's a nice little- it works.
I can't fault Elf. Elf is a very
sweet movie. I like it quite a lot.
We've got on here John McLean and Holly Gennero
McLean and Diehard. Is Diehard Christmas movie?
Yes. Moving on. It's a nice relationship in
this movie because it starts off with them
just straight up, fighting with each other all
the time. And then there's this great moment
where they're trying to figure out
why the terrorists are so pissed off
and Holly's just like, "John's out there.
Only John can make someone this angry."
Which is definitely the kind of thing a
married person says about their spouse.
Sure.
Yep.
Yep. Tracks. Yeah.
We've also got in here-
It's a bleak outlook of romance in this
episode of whatever our show is called.
I don't think we've said-
Said anything good? No.
So, here's one that I really
like actually it's from
a movie that Tom has gone on record of
saying he does not like. Happiest Season.
I love Happiest Season. I have your back.
I really, really don't like Happiest Season.
I really like Happiest Season.
I know that the name of our video here is the most
memorable holiday movie couples. And I'm going to,
I don't know. I don't remember their
names. I probably should have looked it up.
I'll look it up right now.
One of them is named Harper,
Harper and Abby. Their names are
Harper and Abby. Harper is Mackenzie.
Harper is Mackenzie Davis and
Abby is Kristen Stewart. Boom.
Thank you. Now. That's great. I think they are
a great couple, even though they spend most of-
Even though Harper lies a lot.
Well, but that's the whole point of the movie,
which is that she's having a hard
time coming to grips with who she is.
Brian loves-
Now and admitting to herself and admitting
to the world, her actual life, she's keeping
up these appearances. She's horribly
repressed in all of these ways and she's
afraid of the rejection that's going to come
out if she comes out. And what's great about
it is that Abby really does try to stick it out
and try to make it work. And then eventually
the truth comes out and it's
this great moment of Harper-
Like catharsis.
Yeah. And Harper figures out like, "I've screwed
up. I was wrong. This is bad." And I think at
the time too, Abby's just like too little too
late. Bye. And she leaves and then Harper says,
"you're right, please don't leave. I'm going to do
better." And she does. It's like, it's one of the
few times where I think that it's clear that there
is a lot of friction and one partner is really,
really wrong. But at the same time, she's
really wrong in all these very understandable
and very human ways. And so it's more than
just, she has a case of the movie stupids,
you know what I mean? Where it's like she's acting
like an idiot in order for the movie to happen.
No. It's a real reason to be, to
be behaving in this way. Right.
Yeah. And you're not supposed to like the
way that she's acting and you're supposed to
want more for Abby.
You are supposed to root for Aubrey Plaza's
character and Abby to end up together, for sure.
I think it's a great little movie.
I saw, again, I saw it last year
and I'm really ready to see it again this year.
I'm going to, this is going to be a part of my-
I really. Tom You're outnumbered on this
one. I really liked Happiest Season.
The only thing is like-
I'm well aware that I'm outnumbered on this.
Everybody in the world like this accept for me.
Brian, I'll argue you again. I wish not
every single, like LGBTQ love story was like
about like- what something I loved about
Book Smart, not a Christmas movie, is that
Kaitlyn Dever's character is out when the movie
begins and there's no kind of frockus about it.
It's not about coming out.
Not the chief source of drama.
Not every queer narrative needs to be about that.
But I also respect that this one was designed to
be about that and was also created by queer women
and performed by queer women. And so like, great.
It's what it's about.
I love it.
It works. It is the thing that it is.
And I just really, really like it. I
think it's a great movie. And if you
haven't checked it out, check it out.
And you're not Tom.
Tom, you don't like it because you think
that they shouldn't be together. Right?
Because it's a story about somebody who
lies all the time. We don't see or do
one good thing through the entire film. It's
just, it's one woman trying desperately to
figure out why she likes this other woman. And
you never come up with an answer by the end.
You hate liars.
Its just like they're together. And
therefore they should love each other.
So now we know.
Not what relationships is.
This is While You were Sleeping all over again.
This is the thesis of the
episode is Tom hates liars.
I'm not fond of liars. Don't step in my
territory. I'm the one who lies about things.
Everyone's relationships. I think I harpooned
my last relationship by watching Happiest Season.
Just the entire time just spent the whole movie-
Maybe we should not have this part in the office.
Grinding my teeth. Like
why are you still together-
you seem like a perfectly nice
young woman. Go find another,
go find a nice Aubrey Plaza and marry her.
Have a good Christmas. Christmas doesn't
have to be like this. It could be a nice
day. This could be a perfectly nice day.
Tom, are you all right?
I don't know, man. Holidays are rough.
Thanks for watching. Please
hit like and subscribe. Wow.